Randy is with us in Orlando
hi Randy how are you hi I'm very good
yourself better than I deserve what's up
so I'm actually a new listener to the
show and I have a question and it's that
I I am graduating this month from my
undergrad with a health science degree
and I got admitted to a doctoral degree
program of physical therapy and well I'm
gonna be living up to student loans it
should be the program itself is gonna
cost me probably around 130,000 and the
three-year mark and living up the loans
gonna be like 150,000 now I'm married
and my wife makes about 24,000 I was
wondering if she should help me pay for
it she's also going to school but she
helped me pay interest while I'm in
school on the loan I also have a car
note um so I'm sorry okay it's alright
you got a lot going on what old are you
guys I'm 23 my wife is 22 yeah and how
long you been married we got married
we've been married one year okay cool
congratulations on almost graduating
very good thank you thank you good for
you okay well what I do for a living is
I and what I've spent my life doing for
the last quarter of a century is
teaching people the shortest method to
becoming wealthy and living their dreams
okay okay and not letting their dreams
in the process turn into a nightmare
okay my experience has shown with
millions of listeners and tens of
thousands of these conversations and
people we've walked with through many
different decades and age groups and
professions that a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars of student loan debt is
insanity
it's it's not going to be pleasant
there's nothing about this it's going to
be fun
and so I have a 26 year old son and a 30
year old daughter and a 32 year old
daughter so if you were my son I would
say let's try to figure out a different
way to live your dream because I'm
really afraid your dreams gonna turn
into a nightmare the first thing I would
tell you to do is I think you ought to
stop and look at two things immediately
and you can do that tonight and I want
you to do a little bit of research
you're not to do research you're
graduating from college and you can
start with the internet if you want you
can go deeper with the research the
first thing I want you do is I want you
to find several not just one but several
credible sources of what a physical
therapist in the Orlando area makes I
did the research it's starting now out
of school
it's 65,000 minimum you're gonna spin on
that you're gonna spend 150 thousand
dollars in the hole for a 65 thousand
dollar job well it's just the job
outlook
it's the unemployment rate on that job
it's 2% or less and so you better hope
you're employed because you are deep in
the mud yes seamos going to spend
$150,000 come out and they're like a
lawyer yeah yeah yeah and I mean after
the 10-year mark I mean or usually about
six plus they make over a hundred
thousand here in the Orlando area and so
my wife is studying pencil hygiene -
yeah your wife can do that without you
going to PT school and I think you're
gonna be hard pressed to actually go
interview a PT in Orlando that's making
much over a hundred grand that's that's
a fairly rare animal right there we do
coaching and financial coaching for a
living so I get to see and our team gets
to see a lot of people doing a lot of
wonderful things as an RN you can make
as much as you can make doing it being a
PT in most cases and so and actually get
more work and more job stability and
more hours so you know it's okay there's
nothing wrong with being a PT so that's
thing one I'm going to challenge
you're paying too much for a $65,000 up
$200,000 job over six years I want you
to rethink that part but you don't have
to rethink your whole dream just because
you called Dave Ramsey but I'm just
giving you some things to crunch on okay
second thing I want you to do is let's
find another way to skin this cat where
else can we go to PT school it's not so
freakin expensive yeah that's the thing
I mean it's extremely competitive
program the fact that I got in was
already hard you know and then I know
it's tough but I think I may go another
round in it because here's the thing
it's all it's a competitive program but
it's also competitive for them they like
to get the money and the price you're
telling me to get this degree is a
little high dude yeah I up like this
eight schools and I got any one yeah but
go back and look what the prices are on
all those eight okay and you're gonna
see a vast array of prices you're not
gonna see the oh they're all 145 to 165
and you're paying 150 no no you're gonna
find out you're overpaying here thirty
to forty percent just because just
because it's the one you got accepted
into so it's a mixed blessing you got
accepted into an expensive one now I
guess the third thing we can add to the
equation is what can we do to get
somebody else to pay for this like is
there a hot since it's a competitive
market and there's a two percent
unemployment rate in this area you're
saying then there's a demand for pts in
your area maybe there's a hospital corp
in the area that you can work part-time
for and promised contractually to work
for them for a few years after
graduation kind of like you would do if
you went in the army or something right
or went in the Air Force and they might
pay a large portion or all of your
tuition but it's kind of an indentured
servant program where you have to go
back and work for them for a little
while
that kind of thing I'm not as worried
about the price if they're gonna pay for
it instead of you and you could take
this particular one but I'm gonna find
some other ways to do this now you just
call me you just start listening this is
all a brand-new conversation to you and
I just completely just walked all over
your dreams with muddy boots
but I would rather do that than you call
me at 30 to going Dave I'm in a mess we
have three kids my wife the dental
hygienist just quit and went home to be
with a baby
I still have a hundred and sixty
thousand dollars in student loan debt
and I make $85,000 a year would you
please help me get out of this mess
that's the call I get and I don't want
the 32 year old you pissed at the 24
year old you and that's what I want you
to think about so I'm just sitting the
other side of this and I'm not trying to
kill your dreams if you want to be a PT
I think it's a fine profession I want
you to pay a reasonable not overcharge B
to become one I want you to avoid debt
doing it if it takes you a year longer
fine if you got to work a different job
fine if you have to promise yourself to
a company for a little while fine if you
have to go get scholarships fine I'm
okay with all that but I'd be a lot more
comfortable with you paying a hundred
grand to get a degree that takes you
that makes you 60 moving up towards 85
then I would you're doing what you're
doing and I'd be honored and I'm
completely uncomfortable with you going
on despoiling debt to do this now the
problem is you asked me my opinion and
I'm an expert on my opinion but I'm here
to help this what I'm trying to do give
you some things to think about I can
help you further you call me back this
is the Dave Ramsey show